also breaking tonight the new president
unveils his gun control policy
president biden's going after so-called
ghost guns while the nra is vowing to
fight back
also tonight we're learning more about
how the president plans to pay for his
massive spending program
white house correspondent peter ducey is
live tonight hello peter
good evening shannon and we're learning
more about just how flexible the white
house may or may not be
with that infrastructure plan officials
here are saying
that it's got to cover more than just
roads and bridges
and they claim that when republicans are
over here next week they are going to
listen to ideas about how to avoid
raising taxes but how much is republican
input really worth over here
i expect he'll have both democrats and
republicans
attend or join but the republicans they
had over last time to negotiate covet 19
stimulus don't believe the new talk
about bipartisanship 10 gop senators
right
fewer than 24 hours after our meeting in
the oval office the senate democratic
leader began the process of
triggering reconciliation which
precluded republican participation
and allowed for the package to pass
without a single republican vote
democratic senator joe manchin
ultimately voted for
that last stimulus but now claims he
doesn't want the trick
leader schumer used to pass it used
again writing quote
i simply do not believe budget
reconciliation should replace regular
order in the senate how is that good for
the future of this nation
this is how it's supposed to work
senators raise their issues and concerns
and we'll work through the process a
process republicans argue
favors progressives joe biden may have
won the nomination but i think
bernie sanders won the war over what the
democratic party nationally
is these days president biden isn't
waiting for congress to move on gun
control
want to reign in the proliferation of
so-called ghost guns
that part stands out to critics ghost
guns sound scary we're talking here
really are hobbyists
that put together parts for for firearms
the president is also asking the doj
to regulate stabilizing braces for
handguns and
improved background checks as he urges
congress to confirm as atf director
david chipman the national rifle
association's read on today's actions
biden has made clear his sights are set
on restricting the rights of law-abiding
gun owners
while ignoring criminals and foregoing
substantive measures
that will actually keep americans safe
nothing i'm about to recommend
in any way impinges on the second
amendment
they're phony arguments there is some
confusion about the president's position
though is it the president's belief
that you do not have to undergo a
background check when you are at a gun
show
no it's not his belief he believes that
gun that background check should be
universal
but that's not what he said today most
people don't know
you walk into a store and you buy a gun
you have a background check
but you go to a gun show you can buy
whatever you want and no background
check
i was in las vegas for a gun control
forum during primary season and that is
where
now president biden said when it comes
to gun control you've got to have
legislation because it is harder to
undo down the line he was suggesting
that executive actions for gun control
do not work but that is where he is
starting
today shannon all right peter ducey live
at the white house for us thank you
peter